على مر سنوات الماضيه لا يزال التوتر هو
سيد الموقف في العلاقات الامريكيه الصينيه
قضايا مختلفه زادت من تازم العلاقات
ابرزها ملف تايوان الخلافه التجاريه وحرب
اوكرانيا واخرها منطاد التجسس الذي اسقطته
الولايات المتحده التصريحات المضاده
تتواصل بين الجانبين الصين تتهم امريكا
بالسعي الى الصراع وتحذر من الخطوط
الحمراء اما واشنطن فتقول ان الهدف من
زياره بلينكن هو بحث سبل استئناف الحوار
بين البلدين بطريقه بناءه فضمن
الاستراتيجيه الجديده في مسار العلاقات
الصينيه الامريكيه تسعى اداره الرئيس جو
بايدن لابقاء قنوات الاتصال مفتوحه بين
بيكين ولعله الهدف الرئيسي لزياره بلينكن
التي تحمل ايضا في طيتها ابعادا مختلفه
وفق مراقبين لتطورات الحاصله تعزيز
العلاقات بين البلدين خفض التصعيد انشاء
قنوات اتصال مفتوحه ودائمه لضمان عدم تحول
المنافسه الاستراتيجيه بين البلدين الى
صراع هي ابرز التحديات في المرحله المقبله
هنا الاولويه القصوى ستكون من خلال انشاء
اليات لاداره الازمات وتعزيز مصالح
الولايات المتحده وحلفائها والتحدث مباشره
عن المخاوف ذات الصله واستكشاف مجالات
التعاون المحتمل لكن الجانب الصيني يرى
بان كل هذا لا يمكن ان يحصل الا من خلال
تقديم تنازلات من الجنوب الامريكي
والتعامل مع بيكين على اساس الاحترام
المتبادل وليس بمنطق القوه هنا تدربت ايضا
المواقف تجاه زياره بلينكل للصين فمستشار
الامن القومي للبيت الابيض اوضح ان واشنطن
لا تتوقع اي انفراجه في العلاقات مع الصين
وفق شبكه سي ان الاداره الامريكيه تضغط في
الاشهر الاخيره لاستئناف المحادثات
الدبلوماسيه رفيعه المستوى كما فرضت
عقوبات على شركات الصينيه ودفعت حلفائها
بالغرب الى تقييد خبراء تكنولوجيا اشباه
الموصلات في الصين
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات